that's the biggest obstacle or setback
you feel that each of you has faced
personally in your careers you have to
be specific as job was project but just
Center on how you work through it I
think that it's rarely a setback it's
that you get tired sometimes you get
tired and when you get tired then things
start to hit you and you cannot see a
way around you know where is it you have
a good night's sleep sometimes it's easy
sometimes it's hard I think it's the
wear and tear and that's where you
really have to say never get into this
life alone you know get get you always
have somebody to back you up a friend or
or you know in this case we have a
spouse who's a friend well for example
when we have yeah we have the table
which you can talk about in one second
but the whole thing is to say this whole
thing about rugged individualism and by
rebooting apps that's just not the way
people operate you know it's one of my
favorite songs is lean on me and you
know and you know and someday I'll need
someone to lean on and I think that's
really true so it's the day-to-day grind
you know the you always we hope for
something sometimes this helps are
higher than mine so I don't have a big
setback because I'm always a little more
weary than hear that I'm like oh there's
a great old you know know so it's like
much much you know of it's a bigger hit
when it goes down but but still it's
that you know if you don't expect to if
you know that somebody can turn to and
say I'm just down today it's just I just
had a bad day and someone can say it's
okay you've got the you know somebody
can just say it okay keep going
that that's the big I think just dealing
it with it with other people is the
trick and don't don't lock it down you
already talked about the table well yeah
I mean we run this roundtable of writers
and directors and actors and producers
and editors and composers etc that
several thousand people were drilling it
every Thursday for 24 years and it's to
create a compassionate community in
Hollywood and now we have offshoots all
over the country and again it was
because I wanted to create the Hollywood
I wanted to live in and and Holly we can
be very cool
where you down you have to really be
very careful of who you're giving
judgement to who's in judgment of you at
where you internalize that because view
if it's people who are hateful who are
toxic or cruel that can destroy you and
so you have to just find yourself with
people who are loving people who are
kind and it's hugely important and
because at the end of the day you have
to build a life the life is ultimately
more important than this script or this
project or any of it you have to have a
life where you're loved and you're
loving where you have met people who as
well and when you falter will be there
for you and again it has to be you know
lean on me is good if it's if it's going
both ways
it isn't like well let me drain your
lifeforce and leave you an empty husk
kiddo which some people do you know and
so you have to make sure that it's it's
a reciprocal and that's time what we
with the roundtable that we run that's
what we teach and even the classes we
teach where we mentor people what we
often say is your career will be defined
by two poles what you stand for and what
you won't stand for but you have to know
what those two things are and and a lot
of people particularly actors actors can
end up being very successful but feeling
very empty because they're doing roles
but they're not not in alignment with
what they themselves believe and so you
have to decide well what do I believe
what is meaningful to me and then how
can I do work that speaks from that and
speaks to that and because it can uh
there is a habit of executives who are
not artists to sort of project who the
hell are you you know and it's very hard
to answer that but if you know what you
stand for as you say but I take a stand
for the message that I'm going to give
is that as long as you keep trying as
long as you're in the game in your hair
oh you know let's say that's what you
want stand for and if I say well who the
hell are you to say I'm the person who
stands for this message and it's an
important message and they can't get to
you in that way if you really are clear
on what you stand for but but sometimes
it's always hard and the good thing
about like at the table it's even a foot
based you advertise I made five calls
and it's five knows but but then you're
getting applause for having pick up the
phones five times and that you make five
walk
the next day you get applauded for going
the you know you're going the game
you're still fighting on and I think
that we all sort of needed to say hey I
made five calls I'm going to make five
calls tomorrow it's okay that's what it
takes it takes 100 calls to get the one
yes but I'm going to make that 100 calls
when you get that yes and it's very
interesting if you track how people have
struggled that my favorite films if you
listen to like the filmmakers well it
took them 10 years to get it mounted it
took you know lots of insults it took
people you know battering them down but
they ended up making something brilliant
which a lot of people didn't see but
they saw and and they gifted me with it
so I think that it's more realistic to
say hey let's let's applaud each other
for the effort yeah well and also you
know there was a questions asked earlier
about well you know Spacek has taken
five years so far and the beloved part
is we now have a completed rough cut of
the first two hours and we're generating
the visual effects on the first two
hours now and so we get to watch the
story beginning to end
and it's a wonderful story and the
actors are quite wonderful and the
performances are great and the story is
meaningful so that's very heartening as
well once you there's a very distinct
dividing line between when you have when
you have the footage and when you don't
before you shoot before you fit the
footage in the can everything can
conspire to have the thing not exist
so if you stop before you've actually
shot the film or the pilot or whatever
it is then it has it's in great danger
of never existing the moment you shoot
the moment you've got it in the can then
it simply becomes bringing bringing
assets to bear to finish then it's just
a visual effects color correction sound
design those are very doable but you've
got this story it exists it's like if
you write a novel if you finish the
novel every says a book that's beginning
to end
you know and then you can refine it if
normal know how long you took you out
yeah nice write it but it's it's very
important to finish what you start
because first of all if you finish what
you start you know you can finish what
you start and and again again another
enemy is perfectionism you don't want to
have perfectionism stopped you from
starting or stop you from finishing you
know it's very important to
interesting and then refine ray bradbury
who was my mentor for over ten years his
when he wrote he would describe his
vomit than mop which means you write you
pour it out then you refine it but you
start by pouring it out without judgment
and in his youth what he would do is he
would write you would sit down on a
Monday write an entire short story in
one sitting and Tuesday Wednesday
Thursday he would refine it Friday he
would mail it off and then Monday he
would start all over again he was
writing 50 stories a year and an amazing
output and actually he he kept the same
writing schedule for 70 over 70 years he
was amazing man and and a great a great
inspiration yeah I was very lucky that I
got to know him and I go over to his
house once a month for over 10 years and
we just talk about life and art and
career and and I'm actually writing a
book now called my Ray Bradbury that's
about my friendship was read because he
told me many things that were never
never in print never published and I'm
thrilled to be able to share that and of
course a few key members of our team
told us not to start shooting on our
start time for Space command's oh yeah
well that's you know again sometimes
you're very careful of listening to
people who are faint of heart because a
big part of finishing anything is having
the daring to start you know because
again once something is in existence
once it's in motion momentum is
enormously helpful because then people
see that the train is moving and then
they often want to jump on board because
something's actually happening you know
a lot of people they're all talk a lot
of people flake you really have to look
at it look around yourself and who
finishes what they start who actually is
serious about this and affiliate with
those people because there's an energy
that leads towards success and there's
an energy that leads towards failure and
you really have to be mindful of that
and reserve n't and again this is why
I've surrounded myself with you last
night at the table I was mentioning that
I collect show runners now the show
runner is the executive producer who
runs a network show but I do collect
these people I do get to know like if
someone's doing the show that I love
I'll reach out to them I'll go to an
event I'll meet them and then we form a
friendship and a lot of these people are
my mentors they're my adviser
my friends and it goes both ways so
they'll ask me for advice it's funny I
was having lunch a few weeks with a dear
friend of mine who's run a number of
shows he's also a very talented director
and writer and he had just sold a pilot
any was due just couldn't get the story
to work so I said okay if I asked you
and just walk through this with you and
so we talked they said this is this is
what the story is but here's all the
things I don't know and I said oh well
that's easy and I just know here's how
it goes and within about I don't know 20
minutes we totally work the thing out
but that but he you know he had the
courage and the confidence in himself to
be able to say I don't know how this
goes and can you help me and it means
not paying me I'm not being hired and
that's fine it's a two-way 70 the great
thing about Shakespeare in lab yes what
the well Shakespeare went to another
writer to ask to work through a story
point in which Shakespeare and lab the
other friends on both you know really
liked that story but because any writer
knows that you end up frequently
bouncing on the other people yeah yes
because again it's not about being
perfect it's about getting the job done
you